برده شبه غريز بوس
لدينا شراكه ثنائيه وايضا اقليميه وعالميه
اكثر فاكثر وقد شهدنا ذلك خلال الشهور
والسنوات الاخيره في اماكن متنوعه
التعاون الذي ذكرته بشان افغانستان
الولايات المتحده طبعا استضافه القوه
الامريكيه لمده طويله هنا في قطر
شريكا رئيسا من خارجي الاطلس
والعمل الذي تقوم به قطر في بعض الحالات
بالتعاون معنا بالصدعي في النزاعات
الاقليميه والدعم الذي تقدمه للشعب
الفلسطيني والذي يعتبر مهما وحلويات
والموقف المبدئي الذي تتخده قطر بشان
اوكرانيا المساعده لتلبيه الحاجات الدوليه
من الطاقه
وهناك ايضا العديد من المجالات التي نعمل
فيها بشكل وثيق والتي لقطر فيها تاثير مهم
الشيء الاخر الذي ناقشناه اليوم واعتقد
انه مهم والعمل الذين يقوموا به وامنوا ان
ننسق بشكل اكبر جهودنا لتقديم الاغاثه
والمساعده الانسانيه لمن هو في حاجه اليها